[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit heinz
wolf und christian sievers hallo und
guten abend ihn mit schönen grüßen aus
dem kreml hat russland seine
erdgaslieferungen nach bulgarien und
polen gestoppt es sind schöne grüße auch
richtung deutschland an die adresse der
bundesregierung die ja gerade daran
arbeitet all die jahre extreme
abhängigkeit von russischer energie
irgendwie zurück zu drehen um dann
irgendwann auf solche
erpressungsversuche reagieren zu können
wie etwa die polen die sagen wir sind
vorbereitet
wir in deutschland sind nicht wirklich
vorbereitet allein die aussicht dass
kein gas mehr kommen könnte bereitet
großen teilen der deutschen industrie
manager schlaflose nächte der
bundeswirtschaftsminister sieht das land
dagegen langsam auf einem guten weg und
muss gleichzeitig das gefürchtete r wort
in den mund nehmen wenn das gas jetzt
aus bliebe dann rutsche deutschland in
die rezession christiane hübscher mit
mehr als szenario oft diskutiert für die
ersten europäer nun realität in polen
und bulgarien kommt seit heute kein gas
aus russland mehr beide länder waren
gewarnt und vorbereitet putin bestraft
sie dafür dass sie ihre lieferungen
nicht in rubel bezahlen wollten
russland hat diesmal die grenze des gas
imperialismus noch einen schritt weiter
verschoben so der polnische
regierungschef
bulgarien wird nicht verhandeln unter
druck und mit gesenktem kopf so der
energieminister bulgarien ist nicht
käuflich
nicht nur der deutsche bundespräsident
gerade auf staatsbesuch in der slowakei
wird deutlich das ist ein regelbruch
seitens musste und dass es an der
pressung versuch den kann man nicht
einfach hinnehmen gegen den muss man
sich zur wehr setzen bald kam das
notebook aber es ist keine überraschung
dass der kreml versucht uns mit fossilen
energien zu erpressen
auch robert herr beck wird kalt erwischt
eigentlich will der
bundeswirtschaftsminister die
frühjahrsprojektion zur konjunktur
vorstellen das an sich wäre schon
dramatisch genug wir sind vor ein paar
monaten davon ausgegangen dass wir eine
erholte wirtschaft in diesem jahr
erleben werden mit einem großen
wachstums schritt den wir mit 3,6
prozent beziffert haben heute senken wir
die prognose um 14 prozent auf 2,2 pa
weg bereitet die deutschen vor auf eine
inflationsrate von gut 6 prozent in
diesem jahr wegen corona wegen des
krieges fehlende rohstoffe gestört der
lieferketten konservativ geschätzt diese
2,2 prozent wachstum sind ohne energie
embargo oder blockade in der
gaslieferung
prognostiziert wenn diese dazu käme
hätten wir eine rezession in deutschland
wie wahrscheinlich ist das anders als
bulgarien und polen hat deutschland seit
wochen ein zweitkonto bei der
gazprombank wo die euro in rubel
umgerechnet werden um putins forderung
zu erfüllen wenn es doch passiert
bleiben privatkunden vorerst geschützt
was er würde es für die industrie
bedeuten das ist die millionen dollar
frage aber und kurzfristiger schneller
umfassender lieferstopp oder ein embargo
ist wirtschaftlich nicht handhabbar die
deutschen gasspeicher haben sich zwar
seit kriegsbeginn wieder etwas gefüllt
von 30 auf jetzt 35 prozent die
versorgungssicherheit ist aktuell
gewährleistet beim branchenverband aber
bleiben sie nervös wir stehen jetzt mit
35 zu diesem zeitpunkt im jahr relativ
gut da sehr spannend zu beobachten wird
aber sein wie im mai die füllungen
tatsächlich passieren werden welche
initiativen durch die branchen durch die
händler ergriffen werden damit die durch
das speicher gesetz vorgegebenen
füllstände bis zum november 90 prozent
dann auch wirklich erreicht werden der
krieg der nun auch via gaspipeline
geführt wird aber wie hat robert habeck
heute gesagt bange machen gilt nicht
kein gas mehr für polen und bulgarien
und zwar ab sofort das ist ja zumindest
eines nämlich ein klares zeichen dass
die jahrzehntelange gewissheit nicht
mehr gilt die hieß was immer passiert
auch im kalten krieg das russische gas
das fließt es ist definitiv anlass für
plan b szenarien frank umbach ist der
was wäre wenn experte für
energiesicherheit erforscht an der uni
bonn und ist jetzt bei uns gut nannte
rombach
ja und haben da sie das was ist denn
wenn russland heute abend sagen sollte
wie liefern jetzt auch kein gas mehr
nach deutschland
dann hätten wir zwar nicht sofort ein
problem das hat herr habe auch immer
wieder in den letzten wochen wieder
geholt weil wir noch gas in den
gasspeicher haben die sind auch wieder
ein bisschen aufgefüllt worden und wir
gehen ja jetzt im sommer die rote hinein
wo der heizbedarf eher gering ist aber
ungefähr ab juli kommt mir dann wiederum
in dieses hase wo wir ja den gasspeicher
für die winterzeit auffüllen müssen und
da haben wir das problem dass wir einen
globalen gasmarkt eben haben wo es kein
überangebot gibt so wie das noch bis
2020 war sondern ein gas angebot das
gerade für die globale gasversorgung
eben reich deswegen sprechen wir nicht
mehr von einem käufer sondern ein
verkäufermarkt und insoweit gibt es
dadurch erhebliche probleme kurzfristig
für die winterzeit ein zusätzliches gas
zu kommen
ein zusätzliches gas zu kommen aber was
heißt das denn für uns alle hier in
deutschland für die industrie die ja
immer noch wirkliche
katastrophenszenarien aufmacht
und ich teile nicht alle diese
katastrophen szenarien die da im moment
gemalt werden aber fakt ist auf jeden
fall wir haben auf der einen seite die
abhängigkeit von russland in der tat ja
schon reduziert von 35 auf 35 prozent
das ist innerhalb der kurzen zeit schon
ganz beachtlich aber wir stoßen eben
dann an der weiten zuge dieser weiteren
reduzierung der abhängigkeit von mustern
doch an unsere grenzen und deswegen ist
ungefähr ab dem sommer keineswegs eben
gesichert dass wir ohne weiteres die
kompletten 155 milliarden kubikmeter hat
nicht nur für deutschland sondern wir
müssen immer die eu auch sehen
tatsächlich kompensiert werden können
die abhängigkeit reduziert von 55 auf 35
prozent meinten sie gerade in dem ich an
der umbau dann schließt sich jetzt die
frage an wer müsste denn zuerst drosseln
wenn das gas nicht mehr erreicht bislang
hieß es ja immer die privathaushalte auf
jeden fall nicht jetzt meldet sich heute
der aufsichtsratsvorsitzende des
energieversorgers e.on karl ludwig kley
und er fordert bei der gasversorgung
vorfahrt für die industrie die politik
solle sehr ernsthaft darüber nachdenken
ob sie die reihenfolge nicht umdreht und
erst bei privaten abschaltet und dann
bei der industrie denkbar für sie
einen der pauschalität sicherlich nicht
aber man kann natürlich überlegen ob
beispielsweise irgendwelche private
sauna ist wirklich dann geheizt werden
müssen im winter oder nicht also es gibt
schon erhebliche einsparpotenziale die
gibt es aber auch bei der industrie auf
wir müssen immer daran denken dass wir
historisch gesehen keine erfahrung mit
einem solchen erdgasimporte doch oder
exportstopp in dem fall von russland arm
und wir alle relativ unvorbereitet sind
in den letzten wochen sind notfallpläne
erarbeitet worden das war für die
gasindustrie sicherlich schon bekannt
aber für viele andere industrien die an
der weiteren lieferkette hängen für die
war die situation komplett neu und die
hatten der vergangenheit ich jedenfalls
weiß keine konkreten notfallpläne dann
drehte herum braucht zum schluss des
spiels vielleicht nochmal kurzum was
wären denn die folgen für russland wenn
russland die gaslieferungen stoppen
würde klar ist dann wäre erstens kein
geld mehr da es wurde kein geld mehr
reinkommen aber zweitens gibt es
offenbar auch noch enorme weitere
probleme nämlich für die russen selbst
das ist das ist richtig also bei den
diskussionen wird zum wissen über sehen
sobald die diskussionen der letzten
woche wo man häufig argumentiert hat
dass der ölexport mehr geld für den
staatshaushalt generiert das übersieht
so ein bisschen die problematik dass die
erdgaspreise ja dramatisch angezogen
haben und es über sie zweitens das
faktum dass gazprom in der vergangenheit
als der haut exporteur nur von erdgas
überhaupt keine steuern in den
staatshaushalt bezahlt hat sondern
infrastrukturen wie bei den olympischen
spielen in sotschi finanziert hat
tatsächlich würde ein erdgas exportstopp
oder importstopp von unserer seite die
russische wirtschaft und den russischen
staatshaushalt vielmehr treffen und zwar
auch deswegen weil die werte exporte
größtenteils oder zumindest zu einem
teil eben immer noch auf den weltmarkt
gebracht werden kann über tanker bei den
erst gab's da es exporten ist das
überhaupt nicht der fall bärbel russland
auf seinem erdgas sitzen bleiben und
auch bohrlöcher zu schließen
beispielsweise die produktion
abzustellen ist in einer permafrost
rektoren und arktis fast unmöglich und
so weiter trifft der erdgas export die
russische wirtschaft tatsächlich viel
mehr als der
erdölexport wie viele immer
offensichtlich noch glauben sagt frank
umbach experte für energiesicherheit
herum bach danke ihnen für das gespräch
heute abend
100 milliarden euro für die army da
dürfte vielen bundeswehrangehörigen die
ohren klingeln eine armee die knapsen
musste jahrelang und an der ge knappst
wurde steht jetzt plötzlich im
mittelpunkt auch finanziell aber und das
ist das große aber noch sind die 100
milliarden nicht auf dem tisch und schon
gar nicht in den lernen angekommen sie
sind aktuell streitthema im parlament
dass sich etwas ändern muss an der
ausstattung der bundeswehr an der
verteidigungsfähigkeit deutschlands für
diese aussage gebe es locker eine satte
mehrheit im bundestag bei der frage nach
dem wie aber knirscht es erheblich
thomas reich hat es beginnt erstmal
überraschend harmonisch die union einigt
sich mit der ampel auf einen gemeinsamen
antrag zur lieferung schwerer waffen in
die ukraine und gibt damit auch den
versuch auf die regierungskoalition zu
spalten mit einem eigenen antrag wir
wollen gemeinsam mit den ampel
fraktionen die entscheidung mittragen
das schwere waffen an die ukraine
geliefert werden das ist unser
gemeinsamer auftrag und für frieden in
europa zu sorgen bei waffen für die
bundeswehr aber ist es vorbei mit der
einigkeit scholz hat eine zeitenwende
versprochen ein sondervermögen über 100
milliarden euro verankert im grundgesetz
dafür wirbt die ampel um die stimmen der
union
es geht nicht um eine militarisierung
der außenpolitik aber um eines man muss
kämpfen können um nicht kämpfen zu
müssen und deshalb muss die bundeswehr
ertüchtigt werden aus sicht der ampel
geht es dabei auch immer um versäumnisse
der union die in den letzten 16 jahren
die verteidigungs minister oder
ministerinnen stellte wir haben zum
beispiel auf dem papier
350 schützenpanzer puma
davon sind tatsächlich
150 einsatzbereit beim kampfhubschrauber
tiger sitzt nicht anders aus von 51
maschinen
können gerade mal neun abheben schuld an
diesem zustand aber will die union nicht
alleine sein es wird viel mit dem finger
auf andere gezeigt wir schauen uns das
mit selbstkritik an aber hier stehen
herr kollege tor so viele glashäuser und
da würde jeder gärtnereibetrieb vorüber
sein hier stehen wir setzen auch in
einem glashaus die union jedenfalls
kündigt an dass sie dem gesetzentwurf
der ampel für das sondervermögen so
nicht zustimmen werde das ziel in
zukunft zwei prozent der
wirtschaftsleistung für verteidigung
auszugeben werde nicht festgeschrieben
und es sei nicht klar ob die 100
milliarden wirklich nur für die
bundeswehr verwendet würden es geht bei
diesem sondervermögen nicht um
humanitäre hilfe die ist absolut
notwendig dafür stellen wir aber einen
ergänzungs haushalt auf es geht hier um
harte
sicherheitsmaßnahmen im sinne der
vernetzten sicherheit
im ringen zwischen ampel und union um
die größte finanzspritzen der geschichte
der bundeswehr spielen andere fast nur
nebenrollen die afg kritisiert dass
damit sonder schulden außerhalb des
haushalts entstünden die linke das
überhaupt so viel geld zur verteidigung
ausgegeben werde die bundeswehr ist
nicht wegen zu wenig geld kaum
einsatzfähig sondern wegen des
grottenschlechten managements oder
dieses schwarze loch in die das wasser
einfach weitere milliarden steuergelder
versenkt werden nein ampel und union
wollen nun weiter verhandeln so gewaltig
die summe ist um die es geht so groß ist
auch der druck sich am ende doch
irgendwie zu einigen
cdu chef friedrich merz ist der
oppositionsführer und jetzt bei uns in
der sendung guten abend herr merz
genannter siegers die bundesregierung
ist ja ob der brisanten weltlage nicht
unbedingt zu beneiden wären sie jetzt
gerne kanzler
ich bin oppositionsführer und diese
rolle fühle ich hoffentlich aus und wenn
es geht suchen wir auch gemeinsamkeiten
mit der bundesregierung und auch mit dem
bundeskanzler wenn es geht haben sie
gesagt sie wollten die bundeswehr
zeitenwende des kanzlers unterstützen
auch gegen widerstände haben sie im
bundestag am 27 februar gesagt dann
haben sie erst widerstände gemacht und
jetzt doch ein gemeinsamer antrag
zumindest über waffenlieferungen an die
ukraine können sie den bundeskanzler
verstehen der ja sagt deutschland darf
auf keinen fall kriegspartei werden wir
müssen einen dritten weltkrieg
verhindern
ja herr sievers darüber sind wir uns ja
auch einig niemand will den dritten
weltkrieg und niemand will eine atomare
eskalation ich halte im übrigen auch
diese drohung damit für nicht angemessen
wir sprechen hier über das recht auf
selbstverteidigung der ukraine und wir
ringen um die frage wie weit wir der
ukraine dabei auch nicht nur aber auch
mit waffenlieferungen helfen können und
dazu gibt es jetzt einen gemeinsamen
entschließungsantrag morgen im deutschen
bundestag ich begrüße das ausdrücklich
wir haben den vorschlag ursprünglich
alleine gemacht die ampelkoalition hat
jetzt einen eigenen vorschlag
eingebracht und jetzt machen wir einen
gemeinsamen und das ist eine gute lösung
dann bleibt bei einem anderen wichtigen
thema noch viele fragen offen nämlich
dem großen milliarden paket für die
bundeswehr als opposition kann man jetzt
natürlich sagen wir machen eine eigene
agenda wir versuchen offen zu legen dass
es uneinigkeit gibt in der regierung ist
kann man machen muss man aber nicht
unbedingt vielleicht auch nicht gerade
in krisenzeiten für dieses land
zumindest bekommt die bundeswehr dadurch
ja keinen hubschrauber extra also
zunächst einmal herr sievers ist es
unsere aufgabe als opposition
auch auf widersprüche und auf streit in
der koalition hinzuweisen wir sind uns
hier schon unserer verantwortung bewusst
und diese verantwortung nehmen wir auch
war aber wir lassen es nicht zu dass die
regierung definiert wie die
oppositionsarbeit zu laufen hat das
entscheiden wir und das urteil darüber
gibt auch nicht die regierung ab sondern
das geben allenfalls die wählerinnen und
wähler in deutschland ab und wenn wir
das sozusagen vor die klammer gestellt
haben dann sind wir uns in den
sachfragen an der einen oder anderen
stelle einig und an der einen oder
anderen stelle noch nicht einig darüber
reden wir mit gebunden mit der
bundesregierung die bundesregierung
möchte etwas von uns sie möchte unsere
zustimmung zu einer grundgesetzänderung
und das ist keine triviale sache sondern
wir reden hier über 100 milliarden euro
neuer schulden die in deutschland
aufgenommen werden sollen und dass das
vernünftig gemacht wird und dass das
auch so gemacht wird dass das irgendwann
getilgt werden kann das ist unsere
gemeinsame verantwortung und dieser
gemeinsamen verantwortung stellen wir
uns auch das ist keine triviale sache da
haben sie absolut recht und es gibt uns
sehr sehr sehr viel geld trotzdem wenn
sie jetzt nicht zustimmen dann scheitert
das ganze und können sie es sich leisten
dass es am ende heißt friedrich merz ist
derjenige der der bundeswehr das geld
verweigert wir wollen der bundeswehr das
geld nicht verweigern aber der normale
weg wäre dass dies im normalen haushalt
abgebildet wird wir wissen dass auch wir
in unserer regierungsverantwortung dies
in den letzten jahren nicht ausreichend
getan haben aber wenn die koalition
jetzt einen anderen weg gehen will und
dieser weg nur über eine
grundgesetzänderung möglich wäre und ich
spreche hier bewusst im konjunktiv dann
müssen wir den weg gemeinsam gehen und
dann kann es nicht sein dass die
regierung hier etwas vorlegt und uns
sagt ihr müsst jetzt hier ohne wenn und
aber zustimmen aber eben das ist
natürlich ein einsamer auf erreichen den
ich sind wir dann auch bereit zu
erfüllen ich musste aber noch mal fragen
weil dieses diese einzelheiten verstehen
doch die bürgerinnen und bürger gar
nicht mehr so genau am ende bleibt doch
dann hängen die cdu/csu friedrich merz
haben verhindert dass es jetzt deutlich
mehr geld 100 milliarden für die
bundeswehr gibt
und das will friedrich merz und das will
auch die unionsfraktion nicht verhindern
aber wir wollen es so machen dass es
genauso ist wie der bundeskanzler dass
in seiner regierungserklärung am 27
februar gesagt hat 100 milliarden
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr das
ist möglich aber bitte dann auch
dauerhaft mehr als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandproduktes unseres landes für
die verteidigung und das ist gegenwärtig
in den vorschlägen der bundesregierung
nicht abgebildet wir wollen nicht mehr
aber auch nicht weniger als das was der
bundeskanzler selbst vor acht wochen in
seiner regierungserklärung im deutschen
bundestag gesagt hat das klingt ja so
als ob es nicht am ende doch einigen
oder wir wollen uns einigen herr sievers
aber wir sind von einer einigung noch
weit entfernt und ich will es wieder
holen uns das einfach fort zu leben so
wie das jetzt im regierungsentwurf
gemacht worden ist und wie gesagt
bekommen friss oder stirb das ist keine
art der zusammenarbeit und diese
zusammenarbeit wird es dann auch nicht
geben jetzt haben sie vorher schon
angekündigt nur mit so vielen eigenen
stimmen also aus der union dafür zu
stimmen wie die mehrheit unbedingt
braucht um tatsächlich dann diese
grundgesetzänderung durchbringen zu
können das ist sozusagen die idee
abweichler die möglicherweise aus den
ampel reinkommen zu entlarven das ist
natürlich eine oppositions taktik die
sie anwenden können aber mal angenommen
sie werden am ende alle überzeugt auch
in der union von dem von der idee müssen
dann nicht auch alle mitstimmen können
sie sich dann solche taktischen
geschichten leisten sie was das
entscheiden wir wenn wir das ergebnis
auf dem tisch liegen haben und jetzt
will ich mal eine kurze historische
parallele wählen wir haben heute den 27
april 2022 heute genau auf den tag genau
vor 50 jahren hat es das konstruktive
misstrauensvotum der union gegen willy
brandt gegeben und herbert wehner der
damalige fraktionsvorsitzende der spd
hat alle abgeordneten der spd fraktion
bis auf die mitglieder der
bundesregierung aus dem saal heraus
befohlen die durften alle nicht mit
abstimmen weil er sicherstellen wollte
dass kein einziger aus den eigenen
reihen der abgeordneten für rainer
barzel im deutschen bundestag stimmt
also wenn wir das heute in ganz kleinem
maßstab noch einmal erwägen dann hat das
durchaus eine tradition im deutschen
parlamentarismus
also historische parallelen und es geht
auch um letztlich um ein historisches
paket für die bundeswehr friedrich merz
der oppositionschef ist dankt ihnen für
das gespräch
ich danke ihnen sehr
und das gespräch haben wir aus
termingründen kurz vor dieser sendung
aufgezeichnet so wir bleiben noch bei
wichtigen und zugleich teuren
entscheidungen der regierung heizt das
bundeskabinett hat den von
finanzminister lindner vorgelegten
ergänzungs haushalt mit fast 40
milliarden euro zusätzliche schulden auf
den weg gebracht mit dem geld soll vor
allem ein entlastungspaket finanziert
werden deswegen der stark gestiegenen
energiepreise beschlossen wurde
vorgesehen sind eine energiepreis
pauschale von 300 euro brutto für
erwerbstätige eine einmalige kindergeld
anhebung von 100 euro pro kind ein tank
rabatt ein liter benzin soll 30 cent
weniger kosten diesel 14 cent weniger
und für drei monate ein billig ticket im
nahverkehr für neun euro pro monat
bundesbauministerium hitzfeld trotz der
probleme der bau branche infolge des
ukraine kriegs an ihrem ziel fest
jährlich 400.000 neue wohnungen zu
schaffen diese ambitioniert aber die
wohnungen würden nicht zuletzt wegen der
geflüchteten aus der ukraine dringend
benötigt sagte gallwitz bei einem
treffen mit spitzenvertretern des
baugewerbes in berlin die bauwirtschaft
äußerte sich skeptisch und verwies auf
lieferketten probleme und hohe
energiekosten
zudem müssten genehmigungs und
vergabeverfahren beschleunigt werden
die eu kommission hat heute offiziell
ein verfahren gegen ungarn gestartet
wegen möglicher verstöße gegen
rechtsstaatliche prinzipien mit dem
sogenannten eu rechtsstaatsmission ismus
könnte ungarn am ende des verfahrens
eine kürzung von eu geldern drohen
zunächst einmal kann budapest nun zu den
vorwürfen stellung beziehen
in myanmar hat einen von der militär
unter kontrollierten gericht die
entmachtete regierungschef in sanssouci
zu weiteren fünf jahren haft verurteilt
wegen angeblicher korruption
die 76 jährige wies die vorwürfe als
absurd zurück die internationale
gemeinschaft forderte ihre sofortige
freilassung
es ist bereits das zweite urteil gegen
unseren ski und weitere
korruptionsverfahren stehen noch bevor
seit dem militärputsch im vergangenen
jahr steht die
friedensnobelpreisträgerin unter
hausarrest
manchmal ist auch das was man nicht
macht ein zeichen der bundeskanzler ist
nach der debatte im bundestag wir haben
ja gerade darüber berichtet schnell los
in den regierungsflieger auf zur ersten
asienreise und eben nicht nach china wo
angela merkel zwölfmal war immer mit
einer großen wirtschaftsdelegation im
gefolge olaf scholz fliegt über peking
hinweg nach japan das hat mit neuen
gemeinsamkeiten zu tun und mit
gemeinsamen gegnern ulf röller berichtet
das meer schaut so friedlich aus sagte
erzähler aber die welt verändert sich
den frieden zu bewahren dafür arbeitet
die marine mit solchen militär videos
wirbt die japanische regierung für ihre
auf rüstungs pläne das land erlebt eine
zeitenwende
sie ruhig schieber war japanischer
verteidigungsminister er ist eine der
prominentesten stimmen die eine
aufrüstung fordern
es ist war der krieg in der ukraine
rüttelt wohl die bevölkerung was sie
denkt darüber nach wie sie das land
besser verteidigen kann
die allianz zwischen dem chinesischen
präsidenten ski und putin verunsichert
die region japan fürchtet den mächtigen
nachbarn china und diskutiert intensiv
über angriffswaffen
jedes land ob china oder ein anderes das
weiß dass wir angriffswaffen besitzen
und dass wir uns wehren können wird sein
verhalten anpassen
der abwurf der atombombe in hiroshima
hat die militärpolitik des landes
jahrzehntelang geprägt japan gab sich
eine pazifistische verfassung die jeden
militärischen angriff verbietet der neue
premierminister key china ist bereit
dies zu ändern er sucht die nähe zum
militär er will das recht haben auch
offensiv waffen einzusetzen auch gespürt
die zeitenwende
china wird versuchen sich von der neuen
deutschen sicherheitspolitik inspirieren
zu lassen um das gleiche argument
vorzubringen dass japan sich in einer
ähnlichen situation befindet und
anfangen sollte ernsthaft auf zu hasten
presidential wird zunehmend als
bedrohung wahrgenommen japan streitet
sich mit china um ein paar inseln im
pazifik
nordkoreas diktator kim jong un baut
weiter sein atombombe nacional aus das
alles führt zu einem wettrüsten in der
region
um konservative regierungspartei ldp
will den verteidigungshaushalt auf zwei
prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes
erhöhen was einer verdoppelung
gleichkommt
japaner 2020 mehr als 45 milliarden euro
für das militär ausgegeben das aufrüsten
stößt auf den widerstand der
friedensbewegung das trauma des zweiten
weltkrieges beeinflusst bis heute die
japanische gesellschaft
nie mehr krieg das wurde uns beigebracht
mein ganzes leben kämpfe ich für diese
lehre
zeitenwende auch in japan der
angriffskrieg der russen beschleunigt
ein weltweites aufrüsten
und jetzt nochmal zum anfang unserer
sendung und noch mal zu heiß und nochmal
zur wirtschaftsminister habe der heute
wie schon angesprochen auch die
frühjahrsprojektion der regierung zur
wirtschaftsentwicklung vorgestellt hat
demnach wird ein wachstum von nur noch
2,2 erwartet frank bethmann an der börse
wie sind die reaktionen darauf ja selten
war eine prognose von so viel
unsicherheit geprägt krieg fehlende
teile inflation der deutsche
wachstumsmotor ist kräftig ins stottern
geraten der industrieverband bdi betonte
heute eine kurzfristige erholung sei
nicht in sicht es gebe eine doppelte
krise hohe energiepreise und
unterbrochene internationale
lieferketten wegen der erneuten störung
des container seeverkehrs aus china
bremsen die konjunktur
ernüchterung auch beim dihk niemand war
es aktuell wie tief die krise unsere
wirtschaft noch treffen wird bei allen
kommentaren schwingt mit die weitere
wirtschaftliche entwicklung wird
maßgeblich von der dauer des krieges in
der ukraine abhängen und von der frage
ob russland tatsächlich ernst macht und
den gashahn zudreht wie viel weiteres
wachstum das kosten könnte darüber kann
nur spekuliert werden noch aber kann die
deutsche wirtschaft zulegen allerdings
weniger als gedacht war man anfang des
jahres noch von 3,6 prozent ausgegangen
sind es jetzt eben nur noch 2,2 prozent
wichtig für die verbraucher die
regierung rechnet für das gesamtjahr mit
einer inflationsrate von
6,1 prozent
ein grund dafür die rasant gestiegenen
energiepreise gerade die haben die
verbraucherlaune in deutschland
inzwischen auf ein rekordtief gedrückt
zu dem ergebnis kamen heute das größte
deutsche marktforschungsinstitut die gfk
in nürnberg frank bethmann vielen dank
und die zahlen vom lotto am mittwoch sie
lauten wie immer ohne gewähr 3 17 19 25
40 46 die superzahl 8 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf de und im zdf text auf seite 55 7
eine neue crew aus je zwei
astronautinnen und astronauten ist auf
dem weg zur internationalen raumstation
die trägerrakete des privaten
raumfahrtunternehmen spacex hob in der
nacht vom weltraumzentrum cape canaveral
ab die besatzung die fünf monate lang
auf der iss bleiben soll löst dort den
deutschen matthias maurer und drei
seiner kollegen ab
so wie unsere welt von der erde aus
betrachtet aussah das haben wir ihnen
jetzt gezeigt in diesem heute-journal
danke für ihr interesse und um 0.45
meldet sich dann christopher wehrmann
mit dem heutigen update von uns allen
hier ein angenehmer abend wieder sind
[Musik]
die und herzlich willkommen zum wetter
ein kurzer rückblick auf den märz das
war ja der fünftwärmste märz global
gesehen aber lokal war es durchaus
deutlich wärmer zum beispiel richtung
indien und pakistan hier
temperaturabweichung deutlich über dem
normal und da ist ja derzeit eine
massive hitzewelle zu gange es zeigt
also diese karte zeigt dass es also
schon vorher im märz deutlich zu warm
war schauen wir auf das wetter in
deutschland und da haben wir es mit
diesem umfangreichen hoch zu tun auf
seiner ostseite kommt kühle luft voran
und das spüren wir besonders an den
küsten einige wolken sind auch dabei zum
beispiel in der kommenden nacht nach
osten hin also etwas dichter bewölkt als
im westen und im süden teilweise bildet
sich nebel vor allem in gewässernähe und
das bei tiefsten temperaturen von null
grad an den alpen ein grad im vogtland
und im nordwesten sieben grad etwas
milder dann richtung rhein main gebiet
morgenland viel sonnenschein vor allem
in den westlichen landesteilen oder auch
im süden sonst sind auch mal einige
dichte wolken dabei bei insgesamt
trockenes wetter temperaturen erreichen
höchstwerte an den küsten von 12 bis 14
grad je merkt man durchaus als etwas
kühlere luft heran strömt zu als im
gegensatz zum südwesten 20 bis 23 grad
hier ist es also am wärmsten morgen die
nächsten tage am freitag ist es trocken
aber die wolken werden lichter 11 bis 22
grad und spätestens ab samstag gibt es
dann schauer und gewitter im süden und
es ist dann etwas kühler ein schöner
abend